[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Thank you so much for
that wonderful introduction.
And also thank you all
so much for coming.
I think I can echo
practically everybody who's
given a presentation
among the fellows
that this has been one the most
fabulous sabbatical experiences
possible, in every way
possible, from staff
to every fellow that I've had
a chance to interact with.
I've learned a
tremendous amount,
coming in contact with you all.
But you will see that I
am an unfinished work.
You will see that this
project is evolving.
It is evolving as the
days are ticking by.
And I mean, in two
senses of course--
politically the world is
changing in a constant way.
And in addition to
that, we literally
are finding new evidence
and new work, new ways
to try to construct an argument
about international borders
as the days are unfolding.
And we just started playing
with some new data last week.
And I'm going to have the
nerve to show it to you today.
So that kind of makes it fun.
That makes it, to me, sort
of an interesting experience
to run something by
you, if you don't mind.
So that's going
to-- this talk is
going to have that flavor
of running something
by you for the next 45 minutes.
And what I started
this project, I
started collecting this
data about five years ago.
You'll see it's a
very data intensive,
and there's no sort
easy obvious way
to collect information
on the sorts of things
that I want to collect
information on.
I started collecting
the information
about five years ago.
And when I started
this, honestly, I
could not see what was coming.
I really did not
think that something
like a shutdown of the
United States government
would depend on what
kind of architecture
we would or would not
put on our border.
I could not imagine,
for example,
that Brexit would somehow hinge
on the presence of the state
at the Irish border.
Wow, I'd never-- that's not
something I would have thought.
I never would have
thought, for example,
that you would
see a country that
was once says developed
as Venezuela had been,
that it would sort of force
people up to the border
and then refuse humanitarian
aid right at the edge
of its political authority
to assert control.
So all of those things,
to me, are just--
how did the world all of a
sudden get so territorial?
And so this is kind
of what is motivating
this project as a whole.
And in some ways, this is
a sharp turn in my work.
And I'll tell you how.
International political
economy, the way I studied it,
I was very interested in
things like market integration
and constructing
a global economy.
When I studied
international institutions,
I focused on things like
international cooperation
and things that states
did across borders
that created joint gains.
When I studied
international law,
and in particular
international human rights law,
it was all about consistency
of the law across space,
and most especially it was
about the universal aspects
of human rights.
So what are all of
these things missing?
Space.
There's nothing spatial
about anything I just said.
And so this is sort of
like the lens I had on.
I think it was sort of
this liberal world order
sort of a lens.
And then, shock of shocks,
we find the world sort
of chopping into
increasingly sort
of spatialized nation-states
that are reinforcing
their borders in many ways.
And this is what I really
want to try to explore today.
The project that I'm going to
present today, like I said,
it is evolving.
It's a work in progress.
It's got two pieces to it.
One concentrates on structures.
That's what I'm going
to concentrate on today.
There are going to be whiffs
of the other part of what
I'm doing-- it
concentrates on sentiments.
Sentiments looks
at how attitudes
have changed about borders.
When was it in time and
in space that people
started thinking about
international borders
as places--
not so much places of
opportunity and places
of trade and places of
connection and places
where we could create
cross-border multicultural
experiences.
When did they start
thinking about borders
as dangerous places?
Places of risk?
Places of high crime?
Places in which the
other was something
to be feared instead of
something to be sort of reached
out to and contacted?
So we're-- part of this
project is going to be looking
at a broad range of
texts, public opinion,
it's going to have an
experimental component to it
as well.
That is in the planning stages.
That was way too early
to inflict on you today.
But I just want you
to know that that
is where this is going as well.
So structures are a big
part of what I'm doing--
today that's the focus.
But sentiments, and sort
of linking up how fears,
how perceptions, sort of link
up with these structures,
is really where this project
is going to be headed.
So it is true, I think,
it's fair to say,
that political space has
mattered for most of history.
So I think that approximately
three generations of people
learned to order the
world by reference
to a physical political
division-- the Iron Curtain.
And as it fell, and looked like
it was being muted over time,
many people began
to imagine somehow
that the world that we live
in is becoming increasingly
borderless.
And what happened I think
in the heart of Europe
was practically a metaphor
for the world as a whole.
And we imagined that there's
almost nothing stopping us
from reaching out across
countries to anybody,
especially anybody in
this room in particular.
Almost feels like there
is nothing preventing you
from reaching a colleague,
from reaching a family member,
from reaching someone
else in another country.
We live in this ultra-connected
kind of world here
that sort of shows up in these
pairs of Facebook friends.
The other place that
shows up as in the way
that we talk about the world.
A whiff of sentiment
again, if you
want to think of it that way.
So one way to
think about this is
that we were living in an
era that certainly seeped
into global discourse as well.
And just to take a
quick look at this,
you can look at Ngrams, which is
the website that has basically
made available, with
an easy to access
tool, of all the books
in English over time.
And you can put in your terms
with a comma between them,
and you can sort
of find how dense
in the world's
English publications
found in libraries
that language is.
Well, this gives you the
word borderless over time.
I might have used globalization.
It looks almost just like this.
But borderless-- this is the
word borderless over time.
And so you can see that there's
this sharp, sharp upturn
starting around 1990.
I would say 1990
to the year 2000
is this kind of heyday of
thinking about the world
as globalizing,
as being a borderless place,
and thinking about the world
is being increasingly
hyperconnected.
And very few people, I
think, at least people
that I came in contact
with, very few intellectuals
were very familiar with a
different set of circumstances
being constructed by political
forces on the ground.
When the Berlin
Wall fell in 1989,
16 countries had walls on
their international borders.
But if you were to fast
forward and look at today,
a third of the world's
countries have completed
or are building barriers on
their international borders
with their neighbors.
And of the 51
fortified boundaries
that were built up
between countries
since the end of World
War II, about half
were constructed between the
years 2000 and the years 2014.
Those are existing data.
My group has been trying
to document since that time
the creation of new fences,
the creation of new walls,
new barriers, and we cannot
keep up with the number of plans
that governments around the
world have for fortifying
their borders,
building new walls.
Which is to say,
we are not alone.
The United States is
not the only country
in the world that is
having this obsession
with its international borders.
If we were to turn
back to that discourse
again and look for a moment
about the words being used,
we would see that
border discourse
has been changing over time.
So this is that, again, the word
borderless found in the Ngrams.
And if we were to add
another look for a word,
look for the word
border security.
That's what you see here.
The red line here.
So it starts out way
below border list.
But you can see it taking off
very sharply in the year 2000
especially after the year 2005.
This only takes us up to, I
think 2009 in this picture.
It would continue to
accelerate over time.
And it is not just in sort
of in the intellectual world
somehow that this
sort of concern
with international
borders has turned almost
into an obsession.
If we were to go almost at the
opposite end of the spectrum
and look at the way states talk
about international borders,
if we were to go to
perhaps what we can think
of as the sort of central
organ of international security
in the world, the United
Nations Security Council,
we would find something
interesting as well.
What I did was I looked at every
resolution and every decision
of the United Nations
Security Council over the--
since about the
year 2000, and found
something very interesting.
Looking for the word border.
And this is what you see over
time, from the word 2000--
from the year 2000
to the year 2014,
we see something really
quite interesting here.
First of all, the obvious thing
is the increase in citations
overall.
So borders are becoming a really
important and central idea
for international security.
But there's something
else going on here
as well that's really
quite interesting.
That is the context of thinking
about borders is shifting.
So we would expect the
Security Council to be thinking
about security, of course.
But the way they think about
borders is starting to change.
Whereas there are
some of these earlier
debates in the 2000s concentrate
on drawing a legitimate line,
coming to negotiated
conclusions about where
the international
border is or should be,
the context is changing.
Not just to settle your
borders legitimately,
but to control your borders.
To create border security.
To put control
measures into place.
So I think that is another
sort of telling aspect,
this sort of shift
to being concerned
about international borders.
Now, why should we care
about international borders?
I mean, aren't these
spaces that are
kind of empty of people and
kind of kind of out there
with the tumbling
tumbleweeds, sort of thing?
Like you see a journalist,
a windswept journalist
on the border, telling you
how there's no emergency.
And of course, it's usually
out in the middle of nowhere.
It turns out no,
that's not quite right.
Borders are places,
are very important
forms of geospatial governance.
And this is because
people live there.
And I mean a lot of people
live in border areas.
In fact, I looked at a
band of 100 kilometers
from an international
border all around the world
and found that 25% of
the world's population
lives within a land border.
Not even counting the coasts--
we know a lot of people
live on the coasts.
Unfortunately, about 50%
of all violent incidents
and civil wars and
interstate conflict
also occur in the
same 100 km band.
Of course, borders are hubs of
international movement as well.
So some $6 trillion dollars
in international exports
go overland.
It is a small part of the total.
It's a 10% of the
total global trade,
but that is not a small
amount of movement overland
across international borders.
And 25 million refugees,
many, many of which
have had at least
part of their movement
from one country to
another traveled overland.
And so I think that
international borders
are focal institutions
of authoritative control
by the state.
They serve to
demarcate us from them.
Really importantly, they don't
try to block out the other,
they try to filter the other.
So they are efforts to
filter the movement of people
and goods, and in
some sense this
is how sort of
the Weberian state
keeps its exclusive
control over territory--
by creating signs and signals
and structures of its authority
at international borders.
So we're used to be thinking
about how states are governed--
are they democratic?
Are they autocratic?
Are they inclusive or exclusive?
Sort of thinking
about internal groups.
But I think we should
be think about where
they govern as well.
Where they govern
matters as well.
Why?
Because what a state
does on its borders
sends a signal to
a domestic audience
that they take as a
perception of their safety
and their security, or not.
So it impinges on
the extent to which
they understand themselves
as secure from the outside.
Internationally, to
govern in this space
is also to send a signal
outward in a very important way.
To signal cooperation,
sharing, or to signal
hostility and suspicion.
So where is as important as
how, in some very basic sense.
Let me just give
you one example.
Where governance happens
has strong consequences.
It matters whether refugees are
allowed to enter and to make
claims or are
repelled at the border
and not allowed to
make those claims.
So it's very much where
things happen spatially
that matter a good deal.
So I'm trying to work on this
concept of thinking about,
how can we capture that?
How can we capture this idea,
of sort of how much commitment
a state has to make
in the border--
its physical border,
its political border,
international border--
a place where it
demonstrates its authority?
And I'm experimenting, trying
to develop a concept of border
orientation.
What does-- why orientation?
First of all, we had a heck
of a time, a devil of a time,
trying to think of what
the right word is for this.
But we've come up with this
idea of border orientation.
And what we mean by this--
well first of all what
the word orientation
itself means,
it's the relative
physical position
or direction of something.
So in political science, we
think of using the term policy
orientation, and
that signals to us
some kind of a spectrum from
liberal to conservative.
In the business
literature, there's
a big literature on
entrepreneurial orientation.
And this is a literature
that sort of thinks
of a spectrum of risk
acceptance or risk
aversion on the part
of business entities.
In psychology, there's
also references of course
to a character orientation--
introversion, extroversion,
and any number
of scales that we could
think of to measure
the character of a person's
psychological makeup.
We defined border
orientation as the extent
to which the state is committed
to the public and authoritative
display of control over
territory and entry and exit
at its national borders.
So really when are we
kind of thinking of that,
we're talking
about a commitment.
So we're not talking about
sort of fleeting attention
to the border here or there.
It's a state kind
of a characteristic.
That is, these are policies that
are implemented by the state.
Vigilantes wouldn't
count, necessarily
in this kind of a concept.
It's a display of control.
So there are a lot
of ways a state might
control its borders.
If it's not a display of
control, we're not counting it.
So there are other
ways to control
your borders-- land mines
might be one, for example.
Less visible detectors
might be another.
There's no doubt
those are control.
But those are not the
kind of public displays
that we're trying
to get at here.
They don't create the same
visual sense of enclosure
that we are-- and safety that
we are trying to get at here.
And then, and finally, this
idea of control, really
a better word I should
be using is filter.
Because what I'm really
very interested in here is,
the state can control the
terms of entry and exit.
They're not just interested
in blocking everybody out.
Very few states are
interested in that.
Instead they want to
say who, on what terms,
what, what goods on what
terms, rather than trying
to block out the
world in its entirety.
Now this idea of
border orientation,
it cannot be directly observed.
We have to be--
think of ways that we
might be able to uncover
or say something about
or collect evidence
that's suggestive
of this idea of
border orientation.
And so the
observational strategy
that I have been sort of working
on here with a large group
of people is to
think about looking
at border infrastructure.
Why infrastructure?
Visible.
So this is something,
this is an image
that's meaningful
politically and socially.
And it also does
represent a commitment.
You don't put a wall or a fence
down usually and tear it up
in a week.
It is something that sort
of means to stay there.
It has a certain
stickiness to it.
And the other sort
of reason that I
think is really important, that
sometimes we sort of forget,
too, is the extent to which
infrastructure creates what has
been called logistical power--
the ability to shape
the physical environment
to achieve state
or social purposes.
Shaping the environment here is
really very important as well.
So-- and this is something
that liberal theory would just
miss completely.
When we talk about sort
shaping people's behavior,
we usually think of law.
We usually think of incentives.
But we don't so much
think of this kind
of concrete nature of
the kinds of structures
that we're thinking about here.
I'm thinking about organizing
my study of these border areas
in kind of waves, if you
want to think of it that way.
The border is a line.
We can think of that line.
But we can think of
the function of sort
of defending against someone
coming in the first-- defending
or deterring, that is preventing
entry in the first place.
We can think about the function
of filtering through structures
that are meant to make sure
that you are legitimate.
And then we can also
think of a little bit
of ex ante structure as well--
I'm sorry, ex post
structure as well.
So some people get
in, some goods get in,
that we don't approve of.
We can be thinking
of a zone right
after the border that is meant
to see if we can catch up
with the illicit activities
that have made it through.
So I'm thinking of ex ante
defense, entry, and ex post
enforcement around the border.
So let's start with
the first of those.
That would be the border walls.
That's kind of what I began
the discussion with here.
Border walls have some
functionality of course,
and they have a lot
of symbolism for sure.
We would not be--
we would not be even
talking about some
of the political and
public policy issues
we are even discussing
today were it
not for the fact that
walls carry such strong
psychological and symbolic
meaning for people.
Border walls are quintessential
symbols of separation.
They void permission-seeking.
You can't stand
in front of a wall
and make your case for entry.
Can't do that.
They forbid legal trade.
Almost by definition, you
cannot trade legally where
there's a wall on a border.
You have to go to
a port of entry,
which I'll talk about a
little bit in just a minute.
They may have psychological
and attitudinal consequences,
which will be a part of my
research eventually as well.
So we're going to be folding
in a little bit of the look
at some experimental
evidence here,
where our respondents
are queued with knowledge
that a foreign government is
building a wall on their side.
We've already sort
of tested this
in the case of
India and Pakistan.
It's pretty interesting.
When you sort of
ask Indians how they
think their relationship
with Pakistan is evolving,
they'll give you an answer.
And then you say, well, Pakistan
is reinforcing its border
barriers with India.
Now how do you think relations
are going with Pakistan?
Significantly worse.
So that's just been a little
trial balloon that we floated,
but that is exactly
the kind of meaning
that I'm giving to
this kind of notion
of bearing this kind of
psychological impact.
Does it affect perceptions
of official relations?
Does that affect the idea
of interpersonal trust?
Similarity and difference.
Well, so that's what
the plan is to do
when we think of border walls.
But just for now I can tell
you that for sure the number
of border walls and
fences in existence
has gone up very dramatically.
This is around the world.
These are border pairs.
So this is very rough data.
This is just country A
and country B, yes or no,
they have a border, it's
the number of those.
A border wall or fence,
and it's the number
of those around the world.
We're working pretty
hard to see if we
do a lot better than that to
say country A and country B
have one of those.
Instead, what we're
trying to do is
to be very precise
about the geolocation
of these structures.
Be very precise about when
they were put into place.
Because then you can start
thinking about crime diversion,
local disruption, and
even symbolic effects that
start to crop up in the
localized discourse as well.
So the more we can
fight and get more
precise about the
locations, the more we
can do the kind of
microresearch that would end up
to be quite a bit--
quite a bit more interesting
than just saying there
was a wall between two states.
So that's one thing.
That's a pretty strong sort
of indicator, if you will,
of a state's border orientation.
But that's not all.
Let's go in kind
of one level now.
That would be for defense,
maybe deterrence, possibly.
But now let's go to the
places where states are trying
to filter at their borders.
And these would be
border crossings.
Border crossings,
let me tell you,
are places that exhibit
highly conflictual impulses.
These are places where
roads are connectors.
And yet the-- a border is
crossing them like this.
So on the one hand, we
have kind of this impulse
to want to connect
with a neighbor.
That is why we have a
road in the first place.
That's evidence of a motive to
expand, to move, to connect.
These are also, of course,
conduits for externalities,
if you want to think of the
movement of illegal goods
or illegal human activities
of various kinds.
And then they meet
the borders, which
are the institutions
of state control, where
difference of
authority is enforced,
where extraction takes place.
So you might have
to pay something
when you cross the border.
And where protection from
the other is on display.
So we have these kind of
contradictory confluence going
on here.
So border crossings are
state's highest priority
to show their
competence, if you want
to think about it that way.
They sort of-- they
represent-- basically
think of roads globally are
a network of connection,
think of the state and it's
border being the gatekeeper.
And a gatekeeper
functions very important,
the essential locus of
control in any network
is the role as gatekeeper.
So states give this very,
very, very high priority.
So now how do you find the
world's border crossings?
You superimpose a map
of the political world,
international borders,
over a global map
of international-- of roads.
And wherever you
see an intersection,
you presumably have
a border crossing.
So that's what we did.
We superimposed two maps
here, just like this.
These are the gates
of the world--
the red balls, if you want
to think about it that way,
are the gates of the world.
These are two-- this is the
product of two satellite
images overlapping each other.
Each red ball is a crossing.
It's an opportunity
for official actors
to play national gatekeeper.
And so this sort
of gives us a sense
of where we should be
looking for border crossings.
But a couple of things.
It's difficult. It's very
difficult. Roads evolve.
More are built, dirt
paths become highways.
This is not, for
now, a time series.
So this is what we
could see as of 1995.
So these mostly are
still all in place.
But there are many
more, probably.
In fact I will give
you two problems.
Not only are more roads built,
but technology evolves in ways
that we can see more roads.
So now we've got a data set that
basically produces some 9,000
border crossings in the world.
This one produced about 1,200.
So we've got a lot of work
to do, let me tell you.
And it's real tricky
sometimes to sort out
the false positives.
Places-- this is
very interesting
actually-- places where the
road comes up to the border
and the computer thinks
it's going to cross.
That's what the images say,
but no, it's a sharp right turn
and it goes along the border.
Now, what is that?
What do you think that is?
That is a patrol road.
That is state presence in a
very interesting way, which
I don't have anything on today.
But many ideas for figuring out
where those things are as well.
That's a mobile presence
along the border, when
you see a sharp turn like that.
So this is what
we have right now.
And what we can do is we can
throw undergraduate effort
at this.
We can look at every one of
these crossings, and we can--
well, this produces exact--
almost exact latitude
and longitude.
So we can go in with that
latitude and longitude,
and we can say what is
going on at those borders?
What is going on?
What structures do we see?
We're coding for
official buildings,
and we can judge that
by both their proximity
and their symmetry.
Those are the two major
things we're looking for.
We're coding whether we see
barriers across the road,
and we're coding for whether
we a capacity to inspect.
And you can tell
that a lot of times
by the structure of the lanes.
They swing out, they pull--
pull cars or trucks to the side.
And the better developed
that system, the more
dedicated that state
is to filtering.
So then what we end up
with are two extremes--
I'm just showing you
two extremes right here.
These are so easy.
These two are
super easy to code,
because it's just so obvious
that the Burkina Faso
border does not
have anything there
and it is quite the opposite
on the US-Mexican border here
with a very, very high
filtering capacity.
The in-between
cases are so hard.
Let me just say,
they are very hard.
You know, "is that a building?"
sometimes we use the
street view and we
go in and try to look
at it horizontally, too.
Ah, It's.
A gas station, it's not--
it's something else.
But it's not what we
thought it was sometimes.
So when we can we try to
check horizontally as well.
Well, with this
kind of an approach,
you can develop basically
this little kind
of a border presence
scale, if you want
to think about it that way.
And when you take this
scale, from green meaning go,
nobody's going to
stop you probably,
and on the other end
very, very high structure,
all kinds of capacity to
stop you if they want to,
you can then look at the
whole world this way.
Replace those homogeneous
balls with a very
heterogeneous
collection of border
crossing data from
around the world.
So there are some things
are going to hit you
between the eye on this.
Some things are absolutely going
to hit you between the eye.
US is one of the best fortified
countries in the world
on its borders already.
Now this is not
walls here, mind you.
This is not walls.
This is just the border
crossings I was talking about.
What else is interesting?
Look at that.
We see Schengen
right here, don't we?
That's basically Schengen-- this
is the outer edge of Schengen.
And this has a more
authoritarian history.
It's got a little bit
of a different history.
And what else are we seeing here
that's very, very interesting?
Africa does not have
the kinds of structures
that we see in the wealthier
parts of the world.
There's exceptions.
South Africa does.
It is the wealthiest
country in Africa.
Clearly there is a
relationship with wealth.
So this is not all
just pure will.
This is will and
capacity in some mix.
So that's very important
to keep in mind.
Just one other little
thing I want to say too
is a structure like that, a
pattern like that, altitude.
Despite the fact that we
know, and we've actually
recorded some of these.
There's actually one or two in
here that are probably wrong.
But despite the--
a lot of this is
because these are high
altitude locations here.
So you don't need
to sort of put up
filters where there's no
demand to enter, basically,
or very little demand to enter.
So that sort of
gives you an idea.
Now these are averages
for each side.
So that red ball is like the
average of US and Canada.
So let me just break that
up for you a little bit
and give you a sense of when we
look a little closer at the US,
we can see some
interesting patterns here.
The US tends to have a higher
presence than its neighbors.
it tends to build
up quite a bit more.
And in general, the Mexican
border is a little bit more
built up than the
Canadian border.
So this sort of gives
you just a sense
that there is heterogeneity in
the United States, of course,
as well.
Not every place is all built up.
In fact, see this little
spot right down here?
That's Big Bend National Park.
There is a border
crossing there.
It didn't show up in my data.
The reason is our methodology.
There is no road.
There's no road.
Instead there's this.
That's me going across.
That's legal, by the way.
It is legal to do that.
And there is just a sort
of a little rowing facility
to go across the
border right there.
When you come back, you do
not meet a border crossing
person, only a park ranger.
But you have to call
El Paso and tell them
what you've been doing.
So you are required to check,
in some sense, when you reenter.
But this is-- this doesn't
even show up in our data,
to just sort of give you
that sense of heterogeneity
of these kinds of structures.
Let me show you something
else really quick.
This is South Africa.
South Africa, as I pointed
out, the wealthiest
country in sub-Saharan Africa.
And we can see the same
kind of relationship here.
We see more structure on
the South African side
vis-a-vis its less
wealthy neighbors.
So that is a pretty clear
relationship as well.
In fact, the clearest
relationship I have in my data
is that two sides tend
to do the same thing.
So as far as social
science relationships go,
this is very strong.
What we have here is
country one and their score,
and we have here country
two and their score.
If they did exactly what their
neighbor did on their side
every time, you would be
along that 45 degree angle,
basically.
So we can see some outliers.
So we can see, for
example, where's--
South Africa up there does
more than its neighbors do,
for example.
And the US got a
little hidden in here.
United States is
right there, sort of
indicating it's not that
much different from what
our neighbors do, actually.
So there are some--
it's always fun to explore
these outliers, I think.
That is one of the fun things.
But I think the big
question is why?
Why did they mirror each other?
The first thing I think of as an
international relations scholar
is competition.
They're competing
with each other,
basically, one
side does something
and the other side
does something.
It's sort of a, kind of a
competition of some kind.
And I think there may be a
sort of cultural reasons also,
to sort of--
cultural is not
the right reason,
but some symbolic reasons
to mirror the other as well.
If they can do it, we
can do it kind of thing.
So that's a very, very
strong relationship.
But there was one other sort
of-- oh, the other thing
that we should just be
thinking about is homophily.
We get clustering of wealthy
democracies together,
they tend to do the same things.
Like within Schengen. We get a
clustering of poorer countries
together, and they tend
to do the same thing.
So some of that is just
homophily, basically.
There's one other
hypothesis though.
And it is one I
did not think of.
It's one that actually a student
of mine made me think of.
Angie, who's-- Angie,
there you are, right there.
Is to think about cooperation
around the borders.
So maybe it has to
do with cooperation.
So one of the fun things
about this project--
did you get to go places?
When you give a talk in Oslo,
you jump on to an airplane
and you go on up to Kirkenes.
Kirkenes is the northernmost
point of Norway.
It is the only foreign border
crossing that Norway has,
because all other borders
of Norway are Schengen.
And it is a border with Russia.
And this-- you might have
heard this in 2015, 2016--
15-- 5,000 people, Syrians,
North Africans, and Iraqis,
got on bicycles and
crossed the border there
in the winter of 2015, 2016.
It's illegal to cross by foot.
You have to cross on wheels.
So they got-- they
got onto bicycles
and wheeled themselves across.
So this is an interesting place.
That's more people
crossing in two months
than the town of Kirkenes has.
So this was a fairly major
kind of event for Norway.
And so we're talking here
with [? Goran ?] [INAUDIBLE]
and he's telling us all about
his new fence, first of all,
that they built after this
episode with the crossing.
There's a little-- his fence
on that goes 200 meters.
So you can walk
around both ends.
You can walk around
one end and swim around
the other end if you want to.
But the interesting
thing I thought
was very interesting,
I said this
is the Norwegian side right
here, there's the Russian side.
Notice how similar
those buildings are?
The architecture is
very similar there.
And I said to him, I
said to him why is that?
I said, why is it so similar?
And he said, we paid for it.
Why?
we asked him.
And the answer was that
when we have an emergency,
we need to know
who's there, what
room they're in,
where to find them,
how to establish
that communication.
So you know this is all a
matter of border management
and cooperation.
It's not that they're
competing with somehow
the Russians in this space.
It was a need to cooperate,
as he liked to say.
Russia has 14 borders,
and has had a war
with 13 of those neighbors.
And they-- Norway wants
to keep it that way.
So this is what's behind--
maybe, maybe, what's
behind the mimicry.
A lot more work to do.
But it does suggest an
interesting hypothesis.
Now what's behind the
border crossing mimicry
I think is one
interesting question.
But one thing is for sure is
that when we collect a time
series of these spaces, we can
see some interesting build-up
over time.
Now, this keeps
the roads constant.
These are not the only--
these are the same set
of roads, but now we're
looking back in time, which
is a very tricky thing
to do because the
images get very
poor over time going backwards.
So one thing to be-- to
think about, first of all,
is one obvious problem
is that stuff only
accumulates on the border.
You put a building up and
you don't take it down.
Not necessarily.
With a commitment to
liberalize, you can.
And that is what
Schengen has done.
So border stuff
can be taken down.
It can also
deteriorate, of course,
and be allowed to lapse.
So it is not obvious
that just because--
I mean, every once in a while
we would see just sort of places
where you would see a--
what is this, a--
the footprint of where
a building had been,
but it had collapsed, or nobody
was using it, or what have you.
So for the most part,
borders of the world
are going more and more
towards in the direction
of being built up,
filtering structures,
and internal Schengen borders
are going the opposite way.
Which is to say that it's
possible that this measure can
go back down as well.
Now, the last thing
I want to do is
to think about that last
layer, the policing presence.
The policing presence.
Now some-- some unwanted
goods, some unwanted people,
are going to be
able, they're not
going to be deterred
by a fence or a wall.
They maybe sneaked
through, as we
know from listening to
the American debate.
90% all illegal drugs
in the United States
come through the border
crossings, not over--
in other spaces.
So this means that
there's a good possibility
that there are a lot of--
there needs to be a
little ex ante check--
sorry, ex post check--
on the state's
authority and control.
So state official presence
might not be at the border.
It might be in a zone.
And so this prompt
means to look at police.
Police have a role in
controlling entry and exit
by enforcing the
law for people who
then get into the jurisdiction.
So police structures
vary differently--
the police are structured very
differently across countries.
So like in the US you
have counties and cities--
sheriffs and local police.
In Norway you just
don't have that.
They all go through--
they're all assigned
places through Oslo.
[? Things ?] are very central.
And so there's a lot of sort
of variation around the world
in policing structures.
But I think that we can say that
policing institutions at least
are a source of the
state's monopolization
of the legitimate use of force.
It is still an official
actor in some capacity.
So especially since
9/11, ordinary police
have become
increasingly involved
with the enforcement
of, for example,
state immigration laws, even in
states like the United States,
where these kind
of responsibilities
have traditionally not been
part of their job at all.
So where are the world's police?
Where are the world's police?
Who knows, really, right?
Who really knows?
But that's a possibility.
This is a picture of police
stations of the world as
reported in open street maps.
And so this sort of gives
you a sense of where--
this is a wiki now,
it's crowdsourced,
with all of the problems
that introduces into data.
But it's a little bit
of a starting point.
And it seems to
me that there are
two kinds of potential
biases in this data.
Places where people can't go is
the biggest one, because then
they can't report stuff.
So repressive
countries, it's going
to be underreported, probably.
You know the other
place where they're
going to be underreported?
Try to take a photo
near a US border.
They're also likely to be
underreported in border zones,
because you're not allowed the
freedom, often, to take photos,
to document, to ask questions.
You're not allowed the
freedom in border zones
that you are often
allowed elsewhere.
So I think there are two,
at least two kinds of bias
in this data.
So the first of
these can be handled
if we sort of work with a
model of country fixed effects.
The second one of
these in some ways
works against the hypothesis
of observing police
at the border, because it
would be harder for people
to report that in a lot of
these more sensitive areas.
So one very interesting
thing we simply did--
well one thing that I did first
when we were trying to develop
ideas in this area was part of
that border trip that I took
all the way from
Brownsville to El Paso,
crossing the border 11 times--
one thing we did that
was really interesting
was we actually did
contact the police.
In this case we spent
10 hours in a patrol car
with the Val Verde County
Sheriff, Jose Francisco,
or Joe Frank, as he liked to
be called as well, Martinez.
And we spent a good 10
hours in his patrol car.
And one thing I realized is
that police in border zones
are definitely dual
use technology.
They are definitely to
deter from the outside
as well as to enforce
the law internally.
They are clearly,
clearly oriented
towards border concerns.
And I imagine that this
is likely in many parts
of the world as well.
They know the lay of the land.
They know the nature of the
technology on the ground.
So he would show us
where the sensors are.
He would show us
where the cameras are.
where people tend
to come around and through.
And one thing he did
is he would-- he had--
I don't have a picture, but he
had a big pair of binoculars.
And he could look back.
He would just look
this guy back.
He didn't threaten
him, but he was there.
He was a presence.
When he would use
his binoculars,
this guy's just
fishing, that's all.
And that's what
the Sheriff said.
He's just fishing.
He's just fishing, that's
all the guy's doing.
He's trying to give
food to his family.
And-- but when he put his
binoculars up, you could see
there was kind of a moving back.
The guy would go back
to the Mexican side,
and there's an understanding.
There is-- let me
just say, there
is a role for police presence
along the borders as well.
His main message when we went
around this region of the world
was, we have our crime problems,
but it's not a war zone
out here.
Perhaps one reason is that
law enforcement officers
live on almost every
street in his city.
And he was pretty clear
that law enforcement
had a role in border
security as well.
So just to kind of run-- that's
probably the case worldwide.
But there's a lot of work to do.
But one thing that
is quite clear
is the worldwide
police stations are
more likely to be
reported within 50
kilometers of the border
than more interior.
And this is despite the fact
that probably we already
have a bias in the data.
And this is controlling for
the [? log of ?] population,
because of course you're going
to have police stations where
there's population.
And it is controlling
for average lights
at night, which sort of
gives a sense of the state
capacity to provide
public goods.
So even with that, there's
a suggestive evidence
that there's a tendency
to put more presence on--
state presence on the border.
Now, let me just say that we're
not really so much interested
in how much, how many
police are in the borders.
What we're really
interested in is
what each state's
border orientation
is to law enforcement.
So this is what we're-- this
is what our strategy is here.
It's to rasterize
the world like this--
rasterize, put it in these
little kind of squares,
and then to try to
figure out the density,
the relative density, of
police stations per 10,000K
in the exterior zones compared
to the green interior.
That's kind of the quantity
of interest, really.
It is the more
interesting thing to us.
Where are they positioned?
And we found something
pretty interesting--
that is correlated strongly--
ish, for social science--
with your border crossing
presence as well.
So there's a relationship there
with those sorts of things
going on.
Both of those are
weakly correlated
with walls and fences.
Weakly correlated.
They all kind of are moving
in the same direction.
And so these are components
to this underlying idea that
there's something latent
called border orientation,
that these three things
maybe are decent indicators
of, because after all, we cannot
observe border orientation.
That's something sort of
more inherent in a state.
When we take these three
pieces of information, types
of information, and then
we develop a latent model,
we can sort of be thinking
about, again, sort of the way
the world looks in terms
of border orientation.
Again, red-- strong
presence at the border.
Green-- less so.
And we have very close
to the same project--
this is at the--
we can aggregate it at
many different levels too.
This is at the level of
border crossings again.
But we can aggregate
it up now to the level
of bilateral borders
with another state,
because you might have
a particular attitude
towards a particular
neighbor, for example.
And in fact, we can
aggregate further
and say that states
maybe have something
that we might call a
border orientation as well,
the propensity to see
the borders as a place
to exert authority.
Red-- a lot of strong
projection to the outer edges
of a state's
authority, and green--
much, much less so.
There's variance over time.
There's variance by region.
So we can compare
these over time.
We can see that
parts of the world--
North America has the
most, as you could
see from the other pictures.
But we're seeing the
time series in Africa
and the Middle East
are very, very much
upward in terms of strengthening
international borders.
So what explains this?
This is where the
project needs to go.
This is where the payoff may be.
Try to figure out what
explains this kind of a border
orientation?
I think very clearly the
neighbor's orientation does.
We should be thinking about
cooperation, possibly conflict,
but maybe cooperation
in these spaces.
Wealth-- this is a
prerogative of the wealthy.
There is no doubt about that.
When we control for
a country's wealth,
though, what else matters
is the relative wealth
of your neighbor.
So it's not just absolute, it
is differential wealth as well
that matters.
The neighbor's wealth
is very important.
And very importantly, and I've
said this on the CNN post,
walls are something,
and a strong edge
is something that the
autocratic states tend to do.
So sort of think
about what sort of
generates-- what generates
a demand, if you will,
for a hard edge?
Civil society often likes
to move back and forth
and have this freedom
and more liberal states,
more democratic
states, have been
reluctant to have very
severe forms of checking
at the border.
Markets, free markets,
free movement,
civil society strength.
But the autocracies have taken
the opposite kind of attack,
basically.
And so there-- one
thing I think is
that we should be thinking
of these border structures
as idealized forms
of governance.
This is not the way a democracy
does rules, or this is the way
and autocracy does
rules, for example.
We should be thinking
about what it
has to do with
strategies of governance.
International institutions,
regional institutions,
matter to a very
great extent as well.
Very clear in the
Schengen results.
And then finally, I want to
say something about culture.
I have said almost
nothing about it.
We're finding results
already that the states that
have the highest degree
of a border orientation
tend to be more
homogeneous states.
Interesting.
Why would that be?
The sense that we need
to protect who we are.
Is it the sense that
we are homogeneous
and we would like
to keep it that way?
I've not established
causality at anything here.
So I don't know the
direction of causality,
but it'd be very interesting
to know something like that,
wouldn't it?
But to excavate, if you will,
the relationship between
localized homogeneity-- think
maybe of Hungary, for example--
and the desire to exclude and
continue to exclude the other.
And then the other thing
that we've been noticed--
we've noticed
culturally, is difference
in dominant religion.
So if your neighbor--
if the difference between
percent Muslim in each country
is very great, there tends
to be a much harder border
orientation between
the two countries.
It's the same with
Christians, by the way.
So the bigger that
difference in the percent
Christians as well,
strong difference.
And it helps to explain,
if you will, the strength
of the border orientation.
So finally, I just want to
say something really quickly,
and that is that this
is way too much work
to continue to do, have
so many eyeballs on so
many sort of pieces
of architecture
that we need to think
of creative ways
to think about
international borders.
How do you explain
something like this?
This is Tijuana, over here,
and this is San Diego.
Well, you might explain
it by that border fence.
That distinction being drawn
between these two places.
You cannot go from
one to the other.
There is a dam created there.
But there are a lot of other
interesting differences
that don't seem to
depend on a fence.
This is Haiti and the
Dominican Republic.
What's going on?
This is Bolivia and
Brazil, thank you, yes.
This is Bolivia and Brazil.
What's going on there?
Is there truly a
fence all along there?
That's the international
border there.
There's some kind of difference
in land use and property rights
going on here, for sure.
And don't even get me started
on this one, of course.
The Korean peninsula-- we know
that has to do with structure.
But instead of having
a go around documenting
with our eyeballs,
the next step forward
is to be thinking about
computer vision techniques that
will be able kind of scoot
along the international borders,
and say difference, difference,
difference, no difference,
nothing going on.
Maybe we can infer the strength
of international borders
despite that we don't always
see a structure in place.
That's a very-- that's a
strong possibility as well.
So what might we learn,
and then I conclude.
Well first of all,
border orientation
has a strong cultural component.
And this is going to be one of
the more interesting pieces.
Maybe parts of this is obvious
in some sense, other parts
a little bit less so.
Borders, perhaps as we can
get that time series evidence
over time, maybe we can
discover that borders
are thickenings as anxieties
about globalization
begin to intensify.
What is it that people
are so worried about?
And then finally,
and this is where
I think the real payoff
to the project is,
that thicker borders
may have consequences.
And we need to start
to think about how
we would document these.
They might have bilateral
relationship consequences
between neighboring states.
They might have some kind
of impact on security.
And very importantly,
they might have
some kind of impact
on human welfare
that we ought to be able
to document as well.
It seems to me that there may
be very clear human rights
violations in border
spaces that are
highly fortified by the state.
It seems to me that
the kind of divisions
we saw on the Korean peninsula
with that extreme distinction,
we might be able to
geolocate deaths of children
under five years old and infer
the thickness of the border
by not being able to move
to another jurisdiction
for differential
forms of health care.
So all of these
things might end up
being very important things that
we might be able to someday say
something systematic
about, if we
can get the right kind
of evidence in place.
So thank you all very
much for listening,
and I look forward
to your questions.